salir del ordinario escaparé del
ordinario o forget y orinar y como
quiera que ustedes los quieran llamar
pero porque es que queremos llegar a
esto pero primero quiero empezar
diciéndole es una cosa todos aquí
presentes tenemos una meta un logro que
alcanzar hoy tal vez para muchos de aquí
de los que están presentes era pararse
aquí quitarse todos los nervios y
simplemente decir lo que habíamos
practicado por ya bastante tiempo tal
vez para otros puede llegar a ser tener
la casa de sus sueños llegar a tener una
familia o llegar a tener el coche y sus
sueños son pasar el extra de mate
pero para llegar a todo esto porque no
llegamos un día porque no de un día a
otro llegamos a esto porque simplemente
no podemos porque tenemos que superarnos
a nosotros mismos porque tenemos que
superarnos a nosotros mismos porque
tenemos que ser mejores como hacemos
esto escapan el ordinario conociéndonos
a nosotros más un poco mismo y
obligándonos a cambiar para empezar
quisiera montarme en una frase que en
realidad me ha marcado el movimiento es
vida cuando yo les digo el movimiento es
vida que es lo primero que les viene a
la mente
moverse simplemente cambiar de un lugar
a otro pero yo no me estoy refiriendo a
esa clase de a esa clase de movimiento
cuando nosotros nos quedamos en un solo
lugar estáticos nosotros nos estancamos
nos hacemos menos productivos y no nos
permitimos ampliar nuestro pensamiento y
nuestras habilidades como nosotros lo
queremos como queremos lograrlo para mí
no hubo un ejemplo más claro de salir de
que era de mi zona de confort de escapar
del ordinario que para los cuatro años
de edad tiene fia de vida españa madrid
no hubo para mí un ejemplo más claro de
lo que era salir de mi zona de confort
al llegar a un lugar donde había gente
completamente distinta a lo que yo
conocía comida muy diferente a la que yo
conocía la población se movía muy
diferente a lo que uno ya conoce pero
eso es muy bueno porque porque te obliga
a mí me obligó a cambiar pero hacía bien
me obligó a tomar una experiencia de
cada día que pasaba yo cada día que yo
lloraba antes de ir a la escuela y le
decía a mi mamá que no me bajara del
coche
cada día era una experiencia para mí y
cada día fue que yo fui mejor por eso
quisiera entrar a mi siguiente tema
viajar y solucionar una frase propia
bernando que dijo en una de sus
presentaciones para esto quisiera
preguntarles qué es lo primero que
cuando ustedes salen de viaje llevan con
ustedes o ven que alguien lleva teléfono
celular una cámara fotográfica y si
acaso un mapa porque es la realidad y yo
hablemos ya lo han mencionado muchos de
mis compañeros que han pasado aquí
tenemos todo al alcance de un clic
lugares interés sitios que en serio
tenemos que visitar cultura todo pero
que para qué pasaría si nos paramos 20
años atrás cuando no había nada de eso
cuando las personas en serio que
viajaban se quedaban con la pura esencia
con enserio la experiencia con todos los
aprendizajes que ese lugar o esos
lugares tenían para ofrecernos porque es
cierto a veces estamos tan conectados
con nuestros celulares y con las demás
personas que nos desconectamos de
nosotros mismos nos desconectamos en
serio la expert las experiencias en los
lugares y cada cosa tiene para nos para
nosotros
para salir de nuestra zona de confort
quisiera pedirles solamente una cosa no
lo hagan porque tu mamá te lo dijo no lo
hagan porque tu amigo lo dijo no lo
hagan porque tu amigo lo hizo o porque
yo aquí estoy parado o cualquier otra
persona estuvo aquí parada y se los dijo
quiero que lo hagan por ustedes mismos
porque quiero que ustedes tengan las
ganas y el interés de ser mejores por
ustedes mismos
háganlo porque ustedes en serio quieren
y porque en serio ustedes quieren ser
mejores esto me lleva a mi siguiente
punto para ser mejor la motivación por
otras personas admirar a alguien admirar
a alguien es lo mejor que ustedes pueden
hacer porque cada uno de nosotros tiene
cualidades diferentes tienen cosas
diferentes que nosotros tenemos que
adoptar de las demás personas y
aplicarlas para nosotros
para mí no hay una persona que admira
más en mi vida que es mi abuela de 89
años una persona que ha tenido
diferentes cirugías de pierna y ha
pasado por varias experiencias muy
fuertes
de muchas personas de esa edad ni
siquiera teniendo esas experiencias
cirugías etc ya no hacen las cosas que
solían hacer hace 20 años ella todavía
baja a su jardín y camina ella todavía
baja a la cocina y cuando voy a su casa
ella todavía me cocina cosas
para mí no hay una persona que admire
más que eso porque a los 89 años a mí ya
me gustaría y estoy seguro que muchos de
ustedes también les gustaría que a esa
edad siguieran haciendo lo que les gusta
hacer por ustedes mismos esto me lleva
al siguiente punto la automotivación
constante ustedes son su propia
motivación cuando nosotros salimos de
viaje igual día siguiente tenemos un
evento importante
no podemos ni siquiera dormir no podemos
ni siquiera descansar o estamos tan
emocionados que nos levantamos con todo
el entusiasmo y con todas las ganas de
darle con todo ese día porque no tomar
ese mismo entusiasmo y aplicarlo a
nuestra vida diaria y no simplemente
levantarnos y decir qué flojera tengo
que ir a la escuela qué flojera tengo
que ir hoy a trabajar hoy me tengo que
levantar para ir al gimnasio qué flojera
porque no cada día encontramos una
motivación que nos haga levantarnos de
nuestra cama
salir y darle con todo el día porque no
encontrar una motivación para cada uno
de nuestros días
para ser mejor que fue con lo que empecé
y de sacar los aprendizajes es muy
importante que también saquemos los
aprendizajes del fracaso la frustración
y de sus logros porque cree cada una vez
porque de estos tres puntos ustedes
pueden sacar una experiencia y un
aprendizaje porque de cada fracaso que
ustedes tengan se levantan y aprendieron
algo porque de cada vez que se
frustraron porque no podían hacer algo
aprendieron y lo cambiaron porque cada
logro suyo los motivó a seguir porque
también seamos sinceros cuál es el
objetivo de todos nosotros aquí
presentes el éxito el en serio y con el
que llegue el día que nosotros nos
tengamos que ir y decir no me arrepentí
de nada porque es nuestro porque la
verdad es que ese es el punto de
nuestras vidas
como ya les mencionaba el fracaso la
frustración el enojo y sus victorias son
los que los van a llevar al éxito
también quisiera ganarles una cosa el
camino al éxito no sigan no sigan el
camino que alguien más ya pavimento por
ustedes hagan su propio camino con sus
propias victorias con sus propios
fracasos
para finalizar quisiera dejarles una
frase que a mí en lo personal me gusta
mucho y espero que les guste tanto como
a mí salgan
vivan aprendan y corrijan muchas gracias
buenas noches
[Aplausos]